in case you had forgotten
it's pride month i don't think you could
forget that it's pride month because
there are rainbows covering just about
every single inch of this country of
ours it is inescapable the corporations
the media the entertainment the
government it's all sports now it's all
covered in the rainbow well what happens
if you disagree with the rainbow i
disagree with the rainbow
i'm catholic
and we don't we we
oppose the rainbow we don't think that
men can secretly become women
the
christians have a particular view of
sexual ethics
jews for that matter do as well muslims
do as well certain agnostic people do as
well they disagree not to be cruel not
to say we hate you you awful people we
just say look that's not our view of
human nature and sexual ethics in our
relationship to our bodies and one to
another and to our god so we disagree
with that but you're not allowed to
disagree with that anymore there were
some baseball players
who just decided that they weren't going
to wear the pride flag on their uniform
they didn't they just didn't want to
wear the rainbow they felt that it
contradicted their religious belief and
espn this woman at espn sarah spain
blew a gasket
tampa pitcher jason adam to the tampa
bay times hard decision because
ultimately we all said we want is them
to know that they are welcome and loved
here but when we put it on our bodies i
think a lot of guys decided that it's
just a lifestyle that maybe not that
they look down on or anything or
differently it's just that maybe we
don't want to encourage if it we believe
in jesus who's encouraged us to live a
lifestyle that would abstain from that
behavior
sarah spain how does that all come off
to you
pride is about inclusion so you don't
love them and you don't welcome them if
you're not willing to wear the patch and
calling it a lifestyle reveals to me
that you've done not even a modicum of
research or understanding on this topic
it's what tends to happen when a
privileged class isn't affected by
things this is not just about baseball
that religious exemption bs which is
used in sport and otherwise also allows
for people to be denied health care jobs
apartments
children
prescriptions all sorts of rights and so
we have to stop tiptoeing around because
we're trying to protect people who are
trying to be bigoted from asking for
them to be exempt from it when the very
people that they are bigoted against are
suffering the consequences when you say
trying to be bigoted
they're trying to use religious
exemptions
to affect the opportunities
services
of available resources for people who
are lgbtq plus it's bs those religious
exemptions
you don't have a right to your religious
exemption wear the rainbow patch that's
where we are we went from
tolerance hey come on it doesn't affect
you just let people be people let them
do what they want to do
to you will wear the patch or we will
ostracize you from society
we went from hey you know let people who
are a little quirky kind of maybe
explore what they to drag the kids to
the drag show
drag the kids to drag night that's what
they were calling that disgusting event
in dallas
dr drag the kids to a gay bar so that
they can put dollar bills in the thongs
of of deviant men dressed up as women in
front of a sign that says it isn't going
to lick itself that's that's
and we got there in about
six years
it wasn't a very long time
she says this woman is making the
argument
that you you can't tolerate intolerance
that tolerance means
that you've got to wear the patch and
that if you refuse to wear the patch
you're not being tolerant of the rainbow
of lgbt and so that should not be
tolerated that you are a bigot
it is not bigotry to oppose lgbt the
rainbow that is not bigotry bigotry is
the unreasonable attachment to a belief
or a cause
opposing transiting the kids is not
unreasonable transiting the kids is
unreasonable
the transgender activists the lgbt
radicals
they are the bigoted ones that woman
sarah spain on espn she is a bigoted one
and she is a bigoted one specifically
because the beliefs of those baseball
players are reasonable beliefs they are
much more reasonable beliefs than the
drag the kids to drag night it isn't
going to lick itself perverts those are
un the beliefs held by those people
the beliefs held by sarah spain
and the
the rainbow gestapo those are
unreasonable
okay you will comply you will wear the
patch put the patch on that is that is
what's unreasonable it's not
unreasonable to say hey men and women
are made for one another and when a man
and a woman love each other very much
they come together and they get married
and they make baby and we shouldn't drag
baby to the 21 plus gay bars and have
them put dollar bills in the g strings
of weirdos
that's so it's a reasonable view to say
no to that but the point that she's
making that is really important
is
there's no such thing as total tolerance
this is actually a
central point in my book which is out
yesterday in paperback speechless
controlling words controlling minds this
book
there it is wow i missed my old bell
it's so good to have that bell back the
book hit number one as a national
bestseller when it came out last year
it's old enough copies that now we've
got a paperback coming out the point of
this book was not just to own the libs
though certainly enjoyed owning the libs
a fair bit in the book but also to
correct some conservatives here who seem
to believe that we can just tolerate
everything they're the sort of people
who who say
you know whatever happened to the
tolerant left there is no such thing as
total tolerance
because
because either a man can become a woman
or a man can't become a woman
and and those two beliefs are mutually
exclusive and whichever belief a society
holds you're going to have to exclude
the other belief because you can't
simultaneously hold contradictory
beliefs that violates the law of
non-contradiction
you can't you can't tolerate everything
that's what that woman is saying if
we're going to tolerate
lgbt if we're going to be truly tolerant
of transiting the kids then we actually
can't tolerate christianity
or judaism
or islam
or normal traditional standards we can't
we have to pick one
and i for one call me a radical call me
crazy i think the old standards make a
whole lot more sense
than drag the kids to dragnite
i'm glad you like that clip now
smash and click and ring
and subscribe and you will get the
notifications for all of our new videos
coming out also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stooger google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a 5 star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you